[Music]
well more noise was recording
okay
so uh hello everyone uh it's my pleasure
to introduce viet andrin um he's a
currently phd student in the speech lab
graduate center in
kuni
new york university
under professor michael mandel
and soviet has also been before two
times interning at amazon
uh also worked before texas instruments
and today he will talk
about unsupervised and semi-supervised
speech enhancement
so that the floor is yours
yeah
so thank you sebastian for the
introduction
so today i would like to talk about the
topic unsupervised and semi-supervised
speak enhancement
so
from
swami my name is viet ang and my mentor
is sebastian from the audio and occultic
research group
so yeah first of all i would like to
thank you
sebastian and the audio okay research
group
to let me work on the really interesting
project and the cooperation
from the other team
so
yeah so let me first start by discussing
the
problem of speaking enhancement
so
the speaker problem is that we want to
removing noise and vibration
while maintaining speed quality
for example
let me play a noisy input here
uh can you hear it
yeah um so you can see the spectrogram
here as with one exit each time and
another exit is frequency
and you can see that um a lot of speed
spectrogram are covered by noise here
so here is a blind speech
let me tell you again i think
steps through wild adventures down to
the fountain in a stable yard and even
beyond
where paddocks were and the berry
patches yeah so you can see that um on
clean speech the spectrogram is very
clear so you can see some speech signal
here in the red color
or yellow color then you can see some
patterns here
so for speak enhancement the input will
be a noisy spectrogram lasers
or a tie domain signal
because some some speak enhancement they
work on the typing input and some work
on spectrogram input and then what we
want is output
is a clean special program here
so
let me describe why we need speed
enhancement so for human uh is one we
want to improve listening comforts
because um we want to remove all the
background noise for example like
if we have a meeting and maybe there are
some construction outside
or
their advanced noise or a lot of noise
outside
it also can do to improve
intelligibility
for hearing impaired person
or to remove disturbing background noise
and for machine it can help
to remove unnecessary signal so that the
machine can
use the most important signal and then
from that it can improve the overall
recognition performance
many it application
for example from human to human
communication
we can have
right now is really
a lot of people using for example video
conferencing product
like my sub team and zoom
so because we have a lot of people
meeting together
so
if there are unwanted background sound
from one side can affect the meeting so
that's one that's why we want to remove
it
uh also there is um
application in mobile phone or hearing
aids
to human communication
it can yield to be a pre-processing for
machine application for example
for speed recognition
for example like
in microsoft team um after the meeting
we have meeting john griffin and then
the um
the speed enhancement can be like a
pre-processing step before we put it to
other
further processing
it can also help with speaker
recognition or emotion recognition
and
there are many more but i don't have a
chance to
describe everything in here
so
what is the current problems in speech
enhancement
so
most of speech enhancement training data
sets
are synthetic now
so what we do is that we try to mixing
clean speech so we have a data set uh
clean speak that i said maybe we will
record in a
studio with very high quality
professional audio
equipment
and then we have separate noisy cobra so
for example we record some
street noise
or noise on the coffee shop
yeah a lot of noise and then we mix them
together
so
some of the problem is we know that the
studio quality is turning later
expensive because we need to like record
a lot of people talking a variety of
topics
we need a room equipment
also
it's very hard to synthetic every
acute condition that happens in real
world
so that's why
there are no main mesh mask between
synthetics and then real world noisy
speak or audio
so for example if you want to remove
noise on steam
there are a lot of
background happen that we don't have it
on the recording or the noise condition
occultic condition is different because
different meetings have different local
technician
another problem is that the speed
enhancement system with monoi
but because they try to remove noise so
sometimes
um
they are speaking there so like you know
maybe in a tight frequency point there
most big annoying so when you remove too
much noise then maybe the speech signal
it distorts
so that's why it
leads to the problem of um
when you improve the speak enhancement
then the isr performance integration
so
so it's so famous that even in the
google cloud website they mentioned that
however applying no erection signal
processing to the audio
before sending it to serve it typically
really recognize and accuracy so it
means that for team 40 meeting if you
want to make the human noise a human
feel more comfortable
with the speech we should sacrifice the
machine asr
so that is a problem
so how we can
show it
so that's why we have some motivation
and goal for the project
the first one is that we want to
utilize abundant rework noisy recording
for speed enhancement
because like you know that the
conventional methods they have the input
is synthetic noisy we eat clean speak
and noi and the target it cleans big
shows us why the
we need clean speech
but
how we can utilize abundant
noisy recording in here so that's why we
need to
move to unsupervised method for example
we don't use clean speak at target
anymore
we can use a real world noisy recordings
as a target
the second thing is that because the
current real time deep learning speed
enhancement system
often degrades asr performance
so
that's why we try to work
on the public
and then set some goals the first one is
of course
uh we want to improve the perception
quality of enhancement
so um yeah it it tried to improve me
the second thing is that we try to use
utilize abundant rework noisy recording
and using the big data set
instead of the small
clean data set that we have
the third one like we want to mitigate
the
isr performance declaration problem
when we're using speak enhancement
so we want to remove the chat up between
the speak recognition
and speak enhancement
so
the next will be the related work
so in here we describe
one current set of the us for
unsupervised big enhancement
so on the top figure
you can see here
it's a supervised permutation invariant
training
and then the
below figures
is unsupervised one
so in a supervised method
they require the clean speed here for
example
so this signal is um
only single signal
a y in the second one the unsupervised
the
the input not not a clean switch anymore
but it can be a mixture here so you can
see the
red one
and then the brow one here so it is two
signal um mixing together or is
it a noisy recording that already has
inside speak and a signal
so
so from this one they try to propose a
recontracts loss
so that um
when they output all the source here
they summarize to the input picture
and then
um they have some kind of um
contracts checks and lot yeah so that's
why they can do it in unsuper way
however even this one worked very well
for the speech separation task
but it didn't improve
the speed enhancement
um and then the permutation training
here is mean that um
when you have a two source here two
sources here
you don't know
to assign which label two-way source
so that's why they propose a permutation
training so that
if you map the clean speak to
one or two sort it's okay
if that is not a target signal
and then because the mix doesn't improve
speed enhancement
so that's why um recently very recently
there are a paper
that tried to propose noise augmentation
for me
so what they do is that
in the earlier midis they only have the
same signal and the noise recording here
uh mixing with a nice annoy
um so the no recording here is that the
noise already inside the recording and
you cannot you don't
don't have the clean speak
but then
when you record the noise already in
there
um so
um
this one contribution that they
mentioned that they try to add the noise
here
so that um the argument is that when
they add the noise there and then
when the noise here have the same
distribution as annoying additional
noise here
um they expect that the um
the performance of the network will be
improved
um
so
you can see that
i can describe more about the
some letter here so the s spent for
speech inside the recording
and recording is annoying already inside
the recording so for example when i
record there are some background on the
streets
um this
as difficult to know here is that
they have some noise data set and then
they try to add the noise
to the current recording
and then the noise here is the original
noise
in the mickey paper
so
this
the order here i give that because the
noise recording and the noise here have
this in different distribution so that's
why make it doesn't work
and so that's why they tried to add the
end artificial that had the same
nutrition at the end
and then
they charge they hopefully it work
so um
based on the current state of the
unsupervised speed enhancement we can
see some
limitations for example the make it
it does not have strong control
to improve speed enhancement so that's
why they
they don't they don't really improve on
speed enhancement data set
and the second paper augmentation make
it
the test set are not representative
because
it contains synthetic noisy utterances
and
to deploy in real world we want the um
the test set is more it is more on
reward uh utterances
and then
other things that they have in this
guide is my it is a trade-off between
speak enhancement and speech recognition
so every time we improve
speak enhancement speak recognition is
going worse
and then current state of that haven't
addressed us
so that's give us to a proper solution
that we try to utilize the midi slot for
unsupervised training
but we improve it by adding additional
control
so
the constraint is that for example now
we have two output
one is specific and one is noise for
example
and then they sum up together to be the
noisy mixture
but how we can contain that the
one output is contain more space
and another output contain more noise
so the first thing we can think is that
we try to add a this enhancement
constraint
so that two outputs are different in a
specific vector space
and the choice of the vectors where we
will discard later in the experiment
so
here for example we add we make the dot
product of the first output and the
second output to be zero
as the second one is how to make
one output contain more speed
information as possible
so
in this way we try to force one output
to have similar is embedding as a noisy
input
because it is contained similar as
embedding
then we expect the deep output we
contain speed information
so by adding two constraints
we
hopefully might make it
have better performance or speed
enhancement
the third
the third thing uh the fourth thing we
want to do is that we want to utilize a
pre-trained isr
to improve speak recognition
and speak enhancement together so we
want to prevent the chat off
and so here is
our proper network architecture
so we have the speed enhancement
as normal
but in here we have the um
input is a noisy mixture so we don't
require clean speech
the input can be any noisy mixture that
we record whether it's from youtube
or it's from
microsoft team data set
or it's from anywhere
um and then we have add additional noise
this one is
not only recording outside
they
combine together in the title main to
become a signal y here
um and come
to the input of speed enhancement system
so the speed enhancement system had
three output the first one is s
the second one is noi
n1 and the first one is n2
so
what we want to do is that we try to
make the s contain a switch
information the n1
contain where the noise recording
all the additional noise here
and the n2 contain the not whether the
no recording if the n1 content end or it
contain n when the
n1 contain no recording so yeah
so one of not recording or end going to
either n1 or n2
um
here we also have a pre-trained isr
embedding
so
notice that is not a phone isr we only
need it for the task of extract the
embedding for the speed recognition task
and then we take the
noisy speech here
we actually embedding here
and we also take the prediction here
and it tries embedding here
so by enforcing the
laws here
similar to each other
we hope that the speech here will
contain the speed information
um
yeah note that because we don't have a
clean speech at target so yeah
the signal we have here
can be the the s i inventing
um and then um
for n1 and n2 how we inquiry
contain noise so the footing is the um
this sentiment here like we make the dot
product between n1 and n2
um
with s is small so it means that they
contain different information with
respect to speech
um
and then um
we also like um yeah the the midi loss
also
continued for example
they tried to make the s
and n1
combine together to reconstruct the y
here
and then the n2 is similar to the end
so
they make
the n2
contain and or whether they
make n1 contain n
and our loss function can be the
summarizes and
some some of the
the heat loss the inventing loss and the
descent and loss
here we move to the data set
so the training data set
because we want to compare to the
baseline chain on supervisioning so
that's why we include the clean data set
here italy we work with 500 hours
we also using the input response for
revelation augmentation for the
supervisory slide
and then we have the noise data set it
is the dns challenge
with 280 hours
and the noise data set we have rough
select with more than 2000 hours we have
the evolution set uh it is a death owl
which is a speech from that and the
noise from
from out data set
as a suggestion here
and the test set is is the icap 2021
blind test set
and that has the
reward recording with a 700 ultimate
system
and the speed recognition we use a
independent speech recognition engine
it is the micro steam
test set
and using the microsoft i use isr
this dataset have 3000 alternatives with
000 watt
so as you can see here the signal to
noise ratio
of the level and in blue color and the
volt select so you can see like
a lot of living rock has signature noise
ratio very high
um so that's why
we consider it clean speak and then
many of the volks select is um
have low signature know zero so it is 90
speech
the evaluation metric we use
two two kind of evaluation metric the
first one is big enhancement metric
so we have m6 to measure the signal
quality
and back to measure the background noise
suppressant
and and m over o is the weight
combination between signal and
background
because sometimes when you remove a lot
of background noise then the signal can
be um have
have some uh
help reduce the signal quality
all three causes are from then zero to
five and then the higher score
the better
and then because the the human score is
very fancy so we based on a neural
network a lot trained on the human score
level
for evaluation
and for speed recognition magic we just
use the standard word error rate
a weakness level is better
so here
we do
an experiment to see
whether adding additional noise
augmentation can help for supervised
unsupervised training because of
the second paper that i discussed and
they try to add additional noise so
we the input of the network we have to
clean
then
have a free noise which is an artificial
in the diagram
and then with additional noise here
and the target will be clean and free
noise we got it unsupervisioning
so what we can observe that um
we will see that um
the
signal to you know show that have the
back performance actually is when we
don't have any p naught or because the
signal do not ratio is 100
so it means that we almost as no noise
so we
in contrast with the filing in the in
this paper
and here we also we also
ruined that the same
but here we add to noise to the noisy
data set the valve select data set
instead of the
clean data set so we also offset the
same chain like
the higher the signal general ratio
the better the performance so it means
that we only need to add one noise
instead of two noise
also here we
also discuss um the supervised and
unsupervised training result
so the first one
we
the full experiment is the base lines
that we train on a normal loss that's
often used for speed enhancement
so
the input is synthetic noisy by mixing
noisy mixtures
and the noise
so
and the target the noise is fish because
we don't have the clean speed at a hit
here
and the lot is not a standard
traditional supervised
loss
this one can be considered a lower bound
for our experiment
and the second one
aspen tools
either the
original mix
so
yeah the input is the same like noise
big plus noise
the target is not speech but the lord is
the unsupervised make it loss so we
don't use the super violence but we use
unsupervised laws
so
some observation we can see here
the first like here we here is the noisy
one so you can see that the noisy one
the signal is quite good because we
don't remove any signal here so
signal score 3.85
but the background noise is not good
because
it had a lot of noise here
then
the thing here is that the
the noise noisy headboard a wood array
and then
as this guy before every time we add the
speak enhancement by removing noise
then you can see that the signal quality
is reduced so from 3.85 to 3.67
yeah so when we increase the background
input reduce the background noise so the
signal includes background
quality increased from 3.32 to 4.01
then the signal also decreased so that's
why you can see that here
the way light supply leading to
very high water rate
so it increased from
13.29 to 15.71
and then
here we have the result for the original
midi paper
you can see that for the overall
the midi have the same speak enhancement
performance like the same as the
baseline
so that's why in the original paper they
discard that the speed enhancement
using make it doesn't improve
and then here we also offset the same
chain
the reason that the water improved
compared to baseline become i think that
um
they they relieve less background noise
so so that's why
they when they reduce background noise
then the word already better
um and then in here
is our proper methods
so the first one the experiment tree
we do unsupervised training
with make it
but we add an isr embedding loss contain
the explainer 4 here
we
we add the
distance diamond constraint on the isr
impact loss
so we have the
invest
representation for the speech
here
and then we have the
sr embedding representation for the
noise here
and then
we try to make them to be small so like
different signal can contain different
um speak and noise
and then
the final one we can combine everything
like compare the
we contain everything like we add the sr
embedding loss and the decent time loss
so as we can observe here
our proper methods improve the speed
enhancement
so from 3.33
to 3.36
and then we also do the significant that
using the
weak constant test and we found that is
significant
and then in here we also
not only improve the speed enhancement
but we also improve the speed
recognition
so you can see that
the baseline have
15.71
and we reduce the
water rate to 15.07
so it means that we don't have the
church of which we speak like uh
condition and speak enhancement but we
successfully improve on both
and you can see observed here the
contribution on the different
different loss so
when we add decent time we lost then the
m overall improve so from 3.33 to 3.36
um that makes sense because this
sentiment make the
signal and the
noise go into separate channel
so not only overall but you see that the
background yeah the
background also go from 4.01 to 4.05
and the signal keeping the same
uh yeah whatever rate
for the
um
ultra and with low signals general ratio
also improved like from 17
to 732
uh for high signature ratio is also
improved from 6 36 to 6 19 and for the
wood array for the meeting also improved
by 17.83 to 16.95
so it improved on all the
all kinds of
speech life
lows low low noise peak high noise peak
and total speed
um the list that this enhancement is um
not only yeah improve the
overall
um
and then
when we add the
embedding
on this element we can see
the speed enhancement performance keep
the same
and then the
air rate is lower down so
this settlement helps big enhancement
and then the
isi embedding how to reduce the word
array further so you can see that um
compared to the this settlement is all
reduced whatever
also in here another thing to note this
is that um
the extra is embedding on way to v2
and it is a free chain way to uh sr
and then we influence on using the
different sr module it is iusr
so even we use different sr training
and not influence
but the word always still video so we
can make a conclusion that
and the proper methods
generalized to new sr engine
here we also um do
an experiment to measure like where
should we put this entanglement
so there are two ways to put this
entitlement
the first one is we put on the
spectrogram
so
and the second one is we put
after the
isr embedding so um
i can show the diagram again
yeah so there are two way to enforce the
in this diamond the first one we
we try to make the s and the n one here
to be close to each other
and the second one is we put the ice ice
here and the s here to be close together
um
sorry i mean the first one is we put the
s here and the ikea glow to each other
so the spread here the spectrogram
um and then this one is a
embedding after the isr so we make the
ice and
s is similar
so
yeah so we want to measure like which
one is better
so we can observe that um
if we put this sentiment on spectrogram
then the speed enhancement is not work
you can see the score here very low like
2 by
um 14 only so even the background is
improved compared to noisy like 3.32
um to 3.7 d7
but the signal quality
degrade a lot from 3.85 to 2.10
so i think the reason is that when we
try to put this entanglement
then the dot product will be small it
means that they try to force maybe one
split e0
or noisy e0
so it means that in a single thai
frequency point spectrogram
it
it make it contain either speak or noise
but not both
so so binary must
but it's not uh it is not reality
because in a thai frequency spectrogram
there may be some speed signals there
and there may be some noise signals
there
so if we put some kind like um
very strict
like in a spectrogram only
in one point whether they have speak or
noise then it might work well but if we
put this sentence at the isr embedding
level
then it is different because like
it makes like one contains the isr
information and another contain
not isi information so the one that
containers will be speak and another
loan contained isr will be knowing
um so
that's why you can see that this segment
on isi embedding bending
head much better score like improve
the sweet enhancement
we also do some semi-supervised training
by adding a supervised loss on liver and
unsupervised uh on rock select in a
batch
so we can observe that
the
world area total is reduced
and then the speed enhancement score is
similar to the supervised um
so because this one is um
still on training so we expected that we
have a better result when it finished
training
and yeah we can see that even we train
on a supervise
like we have a
clean
data set at target
it has still have higher wattage rate on
than the
unsupervised this one is unsupervised
x.5
we only using noisy dataset and then
the water rate is still lower than the
one tuning of supervised
um but the one tuning of supervise is
better
because it trains on both it can train
to reduce
the vibration and the noise
why in unsupervised way we haven't found
a way to remove the vibration
so that's why you can see that the speed
enhancement score is better
but compared to the one
for a fair comparison with supervisor
one that have
the target a clean and revolution we are
quite close like 3.36 and 3.41
and have much better word errate
and also here
i can play some example noisy they're
set so here you can see the noisy input
the structures housing the apartments
are masonry and frame construction
first they wanted to clarify a
tantalizing bizarre enigma why i charge
money for such garbage
in developing film many toxic chemicals
are used you had to be stupid or crazy
or immortal
yeah so you can see that um ins there
are speak information there and then
there are some background noise for
example the baby crying
and here you can hear the baseline
realize
speech
the structures housing the apartments
are masonry and frame construction
first they wanted to clarify a
tantalizing bizarre enigma why charge
money for such garbage
in developing film many toxic chemicals
are used you had to be stupid or crazy
or immortal
yeah you can see that they
improve
remove some background noise may be
crying
but the speech has some reduction
and here the proof paul metals
the structures housing the apartments
are masonry and frame construction
first they wanted to clarify a
tantalizing bizarre enigma why charge
money for such garbage
in developing film many toxic chemicals
are used you had to be stupid or crazy
or immortal
yeah so you can see that um the the
micro noise remove and then they are
lightly tossed and then the waistline um
i think there are still some little
but yeah
um but it it had to remove everything
the structure is causing the apartment
yeah so uh it leads to our conclusion is
that the original islands do not improve
the speed enhancement
and then the proper methods
that we add additional constraint
by utilizing the isr in bedding
and then the dissentation loss
improved
most big enhancement and speed
recognition so we can see that um
there are no trade-off here
between speak recognition and speak
enhancement
um and then the purple method and
generalized to new acer ending at
influence time
the least sentiment is impacting
representation had a better performance
on us spectrogram representation
um
so i think this can be a contribution
for kind of research because i see that
a lot of people they are doing the
disentanglement
or octagonality at the spectrogram level
and then another thing is that any real
world noises speak opera
could be utilized to improve speed
enhancement by combining superfine and
semi supervised approaches
another thing to notice that because
of the timeline of the project
we use a small
speed enhancement
so
if we can use a bigger speed enhancement
model in our data set we can must
further improve the speed and
enhancement quality and then the speak
recognition quality
so all the report here can be improved
if we use a weaker model
and some future work
like
to mitigate the speed enhancement and
speed recognition
we can do some
things like we try to meaning
maintaining importance with q for sr
when doing speed enhancement so i have
some research on this topic
to finding the important speed queue
and hopefully that in future i can apply
the phd research topic in the university
in the topic of speak enhancement to
make both of them work together
so it's not only
applied to speech
recognition but it can apply to speak
emotion
or
speaker recognition
by maintaining some important speaking
when we doing speak enhancement for that
topic
the second thing is that
the current work we do the permutation
so that's why it takes a lot of training
time
and then there is a current paper
they use the hungari
algorithm
to optimize the permutation problem
so uh yeah by using this we can
optimize the business and competition a
lot for both uh
split uh enhancement and speech
separation
um another
trend of future work can be like
semi-supervised training
and then
we also can do contrastive learning for
speak enhancement
um yeah so the either end of my talk i
would like to thank sebastian
for he mental and guidance
audio hercultic group and deep and
dramatic in the informal learning group
for the usual feedback and circus and on
the project
also i want to thank you human center ai
for the
interesting summer intern talk series
and algo the ic3 ict iii asc
msi and cognition group for the
beneficial and useful machine learning
speed enhancement workshop
thank you and yeah
i hope to hear some feedback and
questions from you
yeah exactly great talk yet
any questions from the audience we have
some time left
unfortunately the noise
the background was from your microphone
was still audible over the
uh
noise samples you played
oh yeah
but i think
the difference was
no questions
so then i'll start off with one question
um
so on this um
this entanglement loss uh term that you
used so this
basically tries to make um
two
representations dissimilar right yes
or similar
uh we try to make it dissimilar
because we make the dot product will be
zero
um but this sentiment here is on f chart
space
so
yeah it's not on spectrogram signals
play but for the isi type abstracts
so
we see we observe that by small object
representation this sentiment in actual
representation is better
than the original spectrogram
representation
okay so but you haven't tried
so you tried to for the spectral
disentanglement
so i'm wondering why this this not did
not work so you try to make the s
the speech and the noise outputs
different right
or something else
yeah the speak and the noise is
different yeah
okay
yeah because i mentioned like because if
we make it in spectrogram space
then it means that similar area and for
the binary mass
in spectrogram like one single time
frequency point can contain only sphing
or noise
but it's not a realistic because in
reality
in one single time we can have like two
speakers or speak annoying at the same
time right
other single frequency mean
um so that's why i think that's why it
didn't work
[Music]
i have a question via sebastian in the
in the mix it
loss that you have on the second line
um i see that you're
both
uh forcing your n1
to go close to the recording noise
and or also go closer to the other type
of noise the additive noise
yes
uh is is there
a reason why you're trying to do both
yeah
um i i mean that um for the original one
this is a original function
but i don't see any constraint that puts
us
to contains fish so they only can train
noise
the end too similar to noi
but i don't see anything that puts the s
here the s predict s
glow to
to the fish right
but i think it is really important
because if we don't contain on s then we
can train on noise
then maybe it's not enough not strong
enough
then how we can contain on s so for
supervised training we have the clean
speed target
so that's why we can easily control on
the speech like we just make the output
of the
network
similar to green speech
but the question is here is
when we don't have the clean state at
target
how we can
control it
so that's why yes i'm betting to make
the because the s i'm betting preaching
it very
robust to noise so we expected that
the
embedding ice impacting of the noisy
space and the clean spec is similar
so even we don't have the clean speak
but we have the embedding uh isi
embedding please uh noisy peak and we
know that is similar to the
clean and then we can use that to
make the contraint on the s
yeah so so that is different
isn't that confusing a little bit the
loss function if you're trying to push
n1
um
if you're trying to push
for example on your mix it lost down
here on the line you're trying to push
the noise and to be close to the
embedding and one but also
and two to be close to n
oh yeah it is a permutation loss
so um it is a lot like we the minimum
here so
because we don't know
[Music]
so basically it's it's you try both
combinations and you take the one that's
that's that has the lower loss
so that's why there's this min operation
right
so this this idea is basically uh from
uh
the permutation invariant loss which is
very popular and so separation
so basically try to separate two sources
but you do this permutation so you
actually don't know
in which output you are both sources and
up
right
but you at least enforce that always
there's the same source goes to that at
the same output so that they keep
consistent over time
that's kind of the idea of this
so do you let the first couple of epochs
decide that and then you stick with
whichever permutation made sense
no it's just per utterance or per
uh training
sequence basically
so it basically tries to enforce con
consistency over time that always the
same source over time goes to the same
output
all right
any other questions
how big is the model
um yeah in here we use the smallest one
so i think it's around two million
parameter
very small yeah
i was cruise 16
so
in your future you
you plan to have a really large model
model like maybe cruise 64 or something
and then use that as a teacher to train
the smaller world
is that one
possibility uh no it's kind of uh
it can be used for any model it's just
uh
it would enable you to to utilize noisy
speech recordings
or basically
then hopefully by by just adding much
more data to your training you might be
able to improve actually
over the just using the supervised
training data that we have
right but
the thing is still lower than
noisy right in your final results
so
do you hope that with the larger model
that that brad that gap will get bridged
yes
a lot more data set and bigger model
yeah okay
so basically he had this one baseline
which is
just traditional
supervised
training like as everyone does
and and he could show like over this
baseline uh there seems to be a little
improvement
uh with this
uh unsupervised or semi-supervised
training at least
right
one minute left
last chance
for questions
otherwise
i guess we thank viet again very nice
presentation
thank you all for attending
thank you vietnam
yeah
and
i will stop the recording and
yeah thank you everyone